day of the workshop on computational and
statistical
trade-offs in interference problems and
rigorous
evidence of thereof
and today we are starting from with two
talks that are coming here from etfl
stream to the whole world and we are
very happy to do that and first of them
is florent tacala that will tell us to
be hard or not be
not to be
the spike madrid sensor model so i will
give him the the stage
and also yeah i forgot to say before
that the the the organizers
that uh majority of the organizers is
actually sitting in the room on our side
there is also a phone so do you want to
say hi
i think
just to prove that
hi
i think i'm on the other camera okay
[Music]
okay i'm i'm sort of waiting for an
official uh notification that i can
start but you should start this too okay
all right uh
okay so
i'm a little bit nervous actually i
never did two seminars at the same time
so that's totally interesting but it's a
welcome change after all these uh zoo
meetings so
it's good to be in person with everyone
in lausanne and in berkeley sort of to
make it feel more real i i made some you
know
homemade
diamonds cup
now i really feel like
i'm in
the building okay so uh let's start
and uh uh
and i will discuss uh
well a trade-off uh between optimality
and
statistical optimality and algorithm so
i'll try to look at the camera from time
to time but sorry guys you know we have
a real audience here so let's see how it
goes
okay um let's start with generic
questions which probably are fantastic
to everyone in this workshop which is uh
which are the following so
take a high dimensional non-convex
problem
you have to learn something so
um there are many things you want to you
might want to do
if you are a bayesian guy and if you are
access to the posterior you might want
to do sampling because this is a optimal
mmc estimator so how hard is it
um
if you are more of an optimization
person you might say no i want to do
maximum likelihood so you might ask okay
how hard is it to compute maximum
likelihood in general
and the sort of question that we ask of
her now okay
how does energy or loss landscape is
influencing what kind of questions okay
so these are very generic questions
and in particular one of the vision we
always heard is that you know you have
stories minimize the landscape and this
police minima are evil and trying to
annoy us
and uh and
since we are in this workshop you might
also wonder how these approaches compare
with mr stressings which
scientific problem is an extremely good
algorithm okay so this is a bit what uh
will be discussed here and in context
um i will try to discuss this in a
very
completely idealized model the synthetic
model which has absolutely no interest
except that we can study it
and this is interesting for me
and what i wanted to find what we wanted
to find my collaborators was a problem
where you know you can compute
analytically what are the optimal
performances
information theoretically speaking
and you can analyze
as precisely as
we don't or we could many algorithms the
behavior of many algorithms so massage
passing sampling gradient descent
and so on and so forth
it turns out there is a model for which
we can do this
which is the matrix transfer spike model
on the sphere
okay so what is it
okay so let me define the model uh it
will not come as a surprise to many of
you
because if you are in the scroll you
might have heard of the spec matrix
model
so here it is so
first uh
take a norm vector on the sphere in n
dimension so
it's l two norm is n
let's call it x star
and this is what we want to find now i'm
not giving you x-star
instead
i'm creating a rank-one matrix
which is x-star transpose plus some
gaussian noise with variance delta okay
and uh and now we'll rescale
best part by sperutofan to make it small
to make it hard
now i'm also creating a tensor not only
a matrix i'm also creating a tensor
around p tensor
is essentially the same kind of object
no it's
plus again uh some gushing noise
and notice here
uh weird factorization we are factor
uh which is just here so that in the
large dimensional limit we have a finite
um
logarithmic ratio but if you don't want
it you know don't take it to just change
the scaling of the noise
all right so now i'm giving you the
tensor and the matrix both of them and
your task is to find back itself
right
very well defined problem
and so this is how we would write it if
we don't want any indices
and so the important parameter of delta
two and delta p i will basically take p
equal to three so delta two and delta
three which are the noise for the matrix
and the noise added to the tensor okay
or the variance of the notes
okay um now if you are a physicist
you should be extremely happy right now
because
at least if you're on spingles theory
you should recognize that this is
nothing but your favorite model it's
called the p-spin glass
model
in particular if you define a cost
function or an italian in this way
well
the margin you know the gibbs measure
according to this hamiltonian which is
written here it's just a posterior
function okay so physicists when they
see this and say oh okay i know that
this is just a p speed you know the
physicist forget it and if you are i'm
sure you welcome
this connection but literally the two
plus p spin model
except that the couplings are the wrong
one perturbation
okay and so
ever you want to sample from this
measure or you want to do maximum
likelihood which is finding the minimum
of ambition
okay so what do we know
what do we know about this model we know
quite a lot
including
some vigorous results actually so as you
know
if you want to see the information
theoretic performances what you should
look uh
what you should compute is the limit of
the logarithm of the partition function
from this you can compute everything and
you know if you are from information
theory you will say oh
information if you're a statistician you
will say no no what i want is a
likelihood ratio
uh or you may want to compute the kudak
labor divergence between the spike model
and the new model they are all given
by viscosity so essentially computing
this
the large end limit is
what you want to do
now this can be done
and more importantly this can be proven
we're quite good at proving this result
now
and for this problem
and formally this is you know what we
know
um
best quantity
concentrates around the max of desktop
so it's a very simple function you know
a function of one parameter you can see
here that we have this uh intensity of
noises
and uh perhaps more importantly once you
compute the max of this function and you
know it's r max you know m star that
maximizes the quantity well the best
means for everyone the minimum means for
error just one minus m star
okay
you can maximize it explicitly extremely
easy and this is what you got so you
even have a value of m
so
i don't know about you for me it's not
entirely clear what m star is from
looking at this you can just plot it
this is m star as a function of delta
two and delta three and you see that m
star there is a region where it's equal
to one
so one minus one is zero it means the
best region the mean square
oh what's the mmc sorry that's not m
star that's mmc
so in the decision the mmsc is one
and this is what a random estimator will
do so it's terrible
so you have a region here where you
cannot learn anything but you know even
the optimal algorithm
would just not give you anything better
than running yes
and there are all this vision when you
can do something
yeah this is here the function of uh
okay so on this side you have you know
what let's go
on the next slide
but what you have is essentially the
intensity of the noise for the tensor
and the intensity of the noise for the
matrix okay okay now let's value let's
forget the value of m star let's just
ask okay isn't star zero or is it
greater than zero
and we have a 2d plot which is probably
simpler to two parts
okay so that's the important diagram
so here i have
the
which is the inverse of the noise on the
matrix
[Music]
and since i'm really crazy and stupid on
this side i'm plotting the inverse of
the signal to noise ratio for tensor
which is a noise on the tensor so it's a
bit stupid maybe we should use the same
convention for both
but we didn't and now we are stuck with
this notation
but essentially what we have here is the
following there is this region here the
red vision
which is the region where the noise is
large for on the matrix and large on the
tensor
where
there is nothing we can do
and uh as far as you know
there is no learning possible and the
m star is actually here okay and then
you have the blue region here
where m star is positive
so at least we can learn here
we can
get a noisy reconstruction obviously
okay
all right so that basically everything
there is to say about uh
information theoretic performances are
here
now what are the best algorithm that we
know for this problem and for their
synthetic problem you would not be
surprised
surprised that this is imp it's a
approximation suspension
so it was written i think for the first
time for this sensor problem by
andrea and
richard
and it's straightforward to adapt it to
the spike matrix and tensor and this is
how it looks if you are familiar with it
you will recognize
you know that this is essentially a
iterative algorithm of these terms which
are called on the terms and the nice
thing about imp is that we can precisely
characterize these performances
through the tools called state evolution
and this is what imp gives you
so imp is uh actually investigation here
able to find optimal performances imp
finds m star
below this line here
imp is not giving you any better than a
random guess
so there is this nice interesting vision
here
where we know that there is a
statistical to computational gap which
is the subject of this
workshop
and so okay here is one of them as far
as we know uh that's the best thing that
can be done so far and of course we are
waiting for someone to to beat this
t-shirt now just a quick comment um
you know there are two interesting
limits that you might consider one of
them is if you are really really adding
a lot of noise to the tensor
and of course if you have infinite noise
in the tensor or you know zero signal to
noise ratio well there is no information
in the tensor what you should do is just
look at the matrix
and uh then you are not surprised to see
that this line is just a bbp transition
okay when you cross vertically here
the transition at one
is just the one where if you look at the
spectrum of the character matrix you
have one eigenvalue goes out of the box
it's literally
um
special
transition
there is another limit which is
interesting which is you know if you
zoom in here
where
you know you have basically infinite
noise on the matrix so you have only the
tensor and the tensor an extremely small
noise if you want you know to do
interesting things you should really
look at this
it's almost non-noisy tensor and here we
have algorithm which can enter the art
phase um
uh for
instance well this kind of tensor
unfolding algorithm and so on and so
forth
and uh we have special method the guys
by um
alex
ahmed and chris and so on and so forth
so this is all interesting i will not be
discussing all this okay we just look at
that delta is finite
okay i'm not looking to his extreme
cases
okay this is all nice and everything but
the question i really want to ask now is
not about imp it's about what about you
know what people actually do
and what people do you know
if you are in a bayesian department they
would just
try to sample from the posterior using
maybe longer maybe more mcmc uh and if
you go to you know speak to anyone doing
machine learning they will say
just
advance in turn you know pytorch and
compute the gradient and do a better
gradient so
how do this thing perform
and that's what i i really want to
discuss here and also how are we
connected with the absence of presence
of meaning
all right
so this can be answered in this model
which is only reason why we did it
so let's do it um
let's first let me tell you what
happened with what happened if you
sample
with the larger than dynamics okay i
don't know about what happened if you do
exactly mcmc but with larger than we
have a pretty good idea just remind to
what algebra is larger is essentially an
algorithm stochastic algorithm in which
at which at each time
well you're
trying to do a gradient descent somehow
and you inject some noise
to make sure that you uh can stay at a
finite empire
okay
now you may ask what happens if you just
run this at long time and we can analyze
that it's one of the you know favorite
tools of mathematicians and
it's extremely popular among physicists
the way we did it was by using this
thing called path integrals because
we're physicists we like fancy things
this is how it looks but never mind that
uh the whole point is that you can
really work hard and derive differential
equation that tells you what is going on
here
and we didn't do it actually people did
it before us
for the spin because it's a favorite
model of spin-less people that was done
by culinary and kerchan as well as the
chrysanthe honor and summers
and
for the problem without a spike
we even have a rigorous proof of this
equation okay that was one of the
beautiful achievements of gerard near
analysts
some years ago so
lo and behold this is what we know
the launch of a
form
perfectly described at this set of
integral differential equations uh
which looks a bit annoying um
but if you solve them
they start here
we tell you
are you overlap
with the hidden assignment we have every
time you start from zero
okay
so you just have to solve this
which you know it's not easy but you can
plug it in a computer
and if you do this you can plug it in
your computer and see what happens
so the this is what happens the first
thing you should realize is that if it
writes imp
after 20 or 30 iterations imp is finding
a positive magnetization or positive
overlap it's pretty fast
larger is doing the same but if you see
my
time scale here
here it's ten to the five ten to the
four so so much much slower
and uh
well it's slower
so you might say fine longevity is
slower
but you know it's a good tool so maybe
if we rail
you know it's just maybe a prefactor and
if you let it run long time
we find the correct uh value arches is
maybe as good as inp
uh so we try to test this assumption
and unfortunately it looks like this
might not be the case so for instance
here this
this is magnetization rich but i'm p
after like 100 or 200 steps okay it's
positive
now base card is what is reached by
launch then after 1000 steps so here
it's perfect it actually find
m star
which is must of course because it's an
algorithm which is sampling from the
posterior so you know at some point if
something correctly
must return you an overlap which is a
base of time
okay a little bit longer and you see
that if you want it longer
at some point it starts to be good here
but when you run out of computer time
and
not clear you know this is going really
all the way to zero
um
so if you want to answer that you have
no choice you look at the equation you
work really really hard you try to do
this and we estimate that
analytically it's not rigorous by the
way we did our best to estimate when it
starts to work
and
we have a line here this is a formula
and larger than works here
in the small region here
longer than does not work in linear time
so it's larger than a half
so that was interesting for us uh i was
not expecting this i was completely
expecting that london will do the exact
same thing as uh
i would have you know i would have told
you of course only a fool
would believe that this is not true but
that's what we found
is laundromat
does launch event work in polynomial
time here just not linear time like are
you having a way to predict
yeah but but okay theoretically what
should happen if i run it for ncube's
time like should it catch up to amp
i don't know i don't know and maybe um
you know i i will not make a guess now
because apparently my attrition is bad
um
okay let me make a guess i think it will
need exponential time but
okay so it might be bad
okay thank you
i really don't know okay now i have one
slide to give you the intuition that we
have on it right now
which is kind of for replica gigs so if
you're not sorry but
this is essentially an understanding
that was made i was not on the paper
actually
so here is what is going on
if you think about the free energy
condition at the given value of the
overlap
okay
uh which is
nothing else than the usual quantity but
you know you have a indicator function
you can plot it it's like this and the
max is m star okay now
imp
is trying to optimize what we call the
replica symmetric potential
we know
that at the maximum
here
the obligation potential is correct in
the sense that it gives you the correct
value here at m star
note that when mp works the potential is
sort of you know it's not it's actually
converts evp starts from here it's going
there
now the thing which is interesting is
that if you compute the replica
symmetric potential the actual potential
you know the actual free energy
condition at the value of m
um
it's not given by the replica symmetric
approximation it's given by lsb there is
replica symmetry
not at the maximum mind you because we
proved the maximum was correct
but for values of m which are not a star
they'd be fair and you have that kind of
you know non-convexity and uh
so
you know i feel like is trapped here
and i don't know how much of an
explanation it is but i think it's
interesting somehow you know the paradox
is that mp is optimizing the wrong
potential and and
since he doesn't know it's impossible
he's doing it
it's doing it and i found it a bit
magical
and so i think this is interesting and
certainly surprising for me
okay part two
part three sorry
what about gradient decent
okay so since we know to do linger
we know to do login descent
we just have to take well we don't know
how to do gradient descent but we know
to do gradient flow it's just linger
when the noise is when the temperature
is going to zero and then this is really
like following radiant flow so we looked
at gradient flow we have the same kind
of equation we can work really hard
blah blah blah and what is going on
well
this is where uh guardian flow works
again there is a phase here where
gradient
flow at long time is stuck in spurious
minima
by the way it works you know a bit less
good as uh
okay that's interesting if you want to
know the formula of s line this is it
okay so this line is perfect agreement
with our simulation so we understand
everything we are really happy
now
one thing you may ask is okay why is
that gradient flow working
and the hypothesis is well probably
because it's stuck in uh minima when
they are minimal so can we actually
compute the property of the landscape
compute how many minima they are in such
models at a given value of the energy
for delta 2 and delta 3 fixed
that we can do this
and this is done by applying the cat's
rice formula
and
actually for this problem
we can compute
that kind of quantity the logarithm of
the expected number of minima
conditioned to be at a distance at the
overlap m
and having an energy
back to the matrix epsilon 2 and with
tensor epsilon b
okay we can compute
these
in fact uh
it's a generalization of uh computation
that was done by gerard
nika a few years ago so we really did it
including the spark okay it's
essentially putting the spike on unless
so we know how many minima there okay
and if you worry that this is a landing
approximation we should not because we
also did it with replica and we checked
that anneal is equal to quench which is
not easy to prove but yeah we didn't
prove it
but okay we all trust perfectly
and so what happened is that indeed we
found an exponential number of minima
and so the kind of naive view that we
have is that you know since i'm in
switzerland i think about someone doing
downslope on the ski lift and you will
get stuck
when they have the highest number of
saddles because they are the most
probable to get stuck
okay
and maybe and that's the kind of
reasoning that was used on the very
similar model by
our friend in new york
now if you increase snr so for instance
delta two is fixed and you increase
delta three or if you fix delta three
and you decay delta two so right so
having a better scenario you may expect
that at some points
there is less noise things are less than
p
and you get the trivial landscape with
only one minima the blue one which has a
positive overall okay and indeed this is
what you find if you look at the
computation
if the snr is large enough you have only
one minima
or two if you have a
event answer
and we can compute exactly when this is
going on
when all the serious minima disappear
okay so let's look when the springs
disappear they disappear here
so that means that
here in between
between the red line
and the black line
gradient flow
is still
still working perfectly fine
even though we still have exponentially
many meaning
right so that's interesting that means
that analysis in terms of just counting
the minima is completely you know naive
and it's not what is going to happen
that's not what matters
so
before
yes
so we're trying to understand um so here
just to make sure that understand
correctly the problem is harder when the
snr is higher and this is kind of the
opposite of the
just making sure that
the direction correct right because
the essence of let's fix lambda p okay
when lambda p is small that's you have a
more
so whenever p is large you have more
signal and then you're on the left
and then the problem is hard yes right
so the problem is actually so problem is
easy when snr is small and becomes
harder when snr increases
yes but
the problem okay yes also you need to
find that the problem is how much i can
find uh
m but yes there are some interesting
effects like this
so how
how is that agree how does that agree
with the caricature you had before
because
i mean usually while they do is the
snr increases and then the local minima
go away
but here
the s r
increases and the local minimum appear
right
we can have a long discussion about this
can we fix delta p
and just be on this line
oh so now you're going up and down on
that okay then then the scenario goes
the right way all right
i see so you're going you're going
vertically and i'm thinking horizontally
okay yeah so think directly
but good point okay and i don't want
service now it's too short
okay so think vertically
and now um
you may wonder why there is a decision
with exponentially many
minima and yet it works
okay and so actually there is a
perfectly reasonable explanation and
this is where i want to go
when you increase the snr
okay these minima disappear but
you know these periods minima disappear
but there's not much you know it's not
that magically they go away
uh in fact they stay
extremely point of the free energy
what happens is they are not enema
anymore and they start to develop you
know they start to be
to have negative
directions
and becoming not minimal but turtles
so the question is what you have to
worry about is including the snr is what
becomes of this minima as you are
training the snr and now you have a bad
joke sorry what you have to worry is
about the thing
and i really apologize for the joke
and
if you look because you can do this and
if you look again to catch eyes with a
bit more
care
you see that literally what is going on
is that these minima start to develop
when you across the snr the negative
direction precisely
in the direction of m star
okay
so
what's going on is that
you got you instead of being stuck there
they actually help you to go in the
right direction and again you know if
you allow me to be cartoonish you ski
there and you avoid everyone else and
you go to the minimum
and if you compute now another line
which is the exact moment where the top
minima start to develop the negative
direction
you have another line
and this one is the correct one okay the
moment where the highest minima develop
a negative direction correspond exactly
to the moment where gradient flow works
so this is literal you know we can see
that this is what is going on
and okay i think this is interesting
because it's one mechanism where we can
understand why you don't get stuck in
that in this thing and i will skip this
otherwise link i will complain
and uh uh i think i'm done
okay so i i presented this uh spiked
matrix model i think it's interesting
because we can compute many things
um
and we have these two interesting
observations
um you know
oh mcmc is not as good as sorry
not as good as imp
that's what i meant
and
we have this model where we can see that
minimizing is okay even though you have
exponential meaning in your market
doesn't matter
and i think this is interesting
and there are many things that you can
do
uh you will hear more about monte carlo
in different topics later on
you can ask the same kind of question in
other problems i think antoine is going
to discuss face retrieval
you can ask what about more complicated
signal and the effect of prior
information and bruno is going to
discuss this
or you may want to go into a neural
network and more complicated problem and
maybe different kind of optimization
algorithm and there is a line of work by
lenka and there's the election so now we
really stop just flashing the papers
that correspond to the stock
and uh i'm
happy to take questions i don't know if
we have time probably not
these are immediate questions while
bruno is setting up because
we have some questions on this side
[Music]
okay
in your i'm still confused about the
answer to nazi's questions so in your
phase diagram
suppose that i insist on going
horizontally right like yeah then then
it does seem like uh something super
strange is happening right because i
could always i can always just ignore
the tensor
and all right
use the matrix
so let me tell you
okay i'm totally cheating you guys
because the best algorithm is the
following ignore the tensor
then just look at the matrix take the
leading value of the noisy matrix and
initialize your algorithm there and then
you are basically as good as i am
yeah
well okay but the initialization the
only the only benefit of the
initialization is that it slightly
increases your correlation with plants
like sorry
initialization no the benefit of the
initialization is getting you to
anything decent and then if you run your
algorithm a little bit after the
initialization you'll like slightly
increase your correlation with uh
with with the plastic
if you start by run you know all these
things which are happening which are
funny is that if you start randomly
well you don't seem to you know
algorithm doesn't seem to realize that
there is this information and indeed if
you start randomly
it looks i mean it's actually true it's
better to to
if you start randomly on the you start
randomly on the landscape that you have
insisted on by by taking like the
by taking the matrix and tensor
information all together and packaging
it up into this free energy landscape or
not free energy landscape into the you
know the like likelihood landscape
okay okay so so calling it a hard region
is like it's hard for a particular
algorithm but it's not like it's hard
for polynomial time in that region
actually you know imp is perfectly fine
and i've just told you if you initialize
with the with the special initialization
you're all fine now okay
it's hard for all algorithm i know
you don't even need to initialize the
spectrum all you need to do is ignore
the tensor right if i just
run a random initialization um and they
just run on the metrics right so it
seems what's going on here
so if you increase the tensor afterward
you strengthen the information and you
are even better better overlap uh
yes but in terms of the transition of
like recovery or non-recovery you're
fine right
so kind of what's going on here
finishing correctly
the
there's just two two problems
that give you information about the same
thing
and one of them is is hard it's
computationally hard and you're just
hurting yourself by paying attention to
it
uh that's correct
yourself in the initial search you're
hurting yourself in the initial search
phase but then there's some there's some
potential if you if you could get close
ish then you could use that information
a little bit for some cleanup perhaps we
don't see that
perhaps yeah
to be perfectly clear we it's all of us
is true yeah my difficulty is completely
artificial
however the advantage is that the best
model i can compute everything
is good why why is the mp able to ignore
the sensor because imp at the first
steps what he's actually doing is you
know
the matrix part is actually acting like
a like a spectral algorithm and these
these better amps from like alex and so
on would they also be able to do this or
would they get stuck in the tent oh well
that you have to ask alex i think they
would work but uh
you know i don't think they you know
analyzing np super hard but they they
analyze the spectral version of them
alex can you hear my question or no yeah
i think if you run kikuchi it would work
fine the same as amp i would imagine
yeah
yeah yeah i mean you know as i told you
there is no real computational
difficulty here it's just a toy model
where we can actually look what would
happen if i you know just run off the
shelf algorithm
and uh
they are not working so well
and it's interesting to know why
it's okay